they wait and they wait it's so quiet on
the taxi rank outside Manchester Airport
the drivers now call it the library
unless it but the majority of planes are
just not moving just ten flights landed
at Manchester today and now there's 14
days quarantine for almost everyone who
arrives in the UK it also applies to
people on ferries from mainland Europe
and international trains running into
London's and Pancras it's fine I don't
really mind actually I think it's a good
way of protecting each other I didn't
know if I okay I'm carrying something
and I don't know if I can give it to
someone else we're now at a tipping
point where we've got to keep people
healthy and try and save the economy and
keep the world moving somewhat
passengers have been warned that the UK
authorities could phone or even call at
your door to check that you're in but
the net effect is that many people just
won't travel they won't book summer
holidays abroad the cost of all this is
almost impossible to calculate the
travel industry is on its knees and many
within it say that quarantine will keep
it there there are other options in
Austria you can just take a test instead
of 14 days quarantine trials around
things like temperature checking we're
giving face masks to everybody who
travels we don't know if a process
involving testing
or will actually be the answer and
they're all things that were really
willing to talk to the government about
on trial many scientists have questioned
the effectiveness of quarantine that the
UK government insists that it is the
right way ahead they will review the
policy every three weeks
Tom Parmenter Sky News Manchester
Airport